thank you
[Music]
welcome to another wonderful episode of
careful boys we have with us today Miss
Colleen Reinhardt oh
hey I just wanted to know um throughout
your life have any of you guys fallen
for any scams
I feel like I can probably find one for
right now but I don't know but what do
you mean by that well you're you you
could be the guy who's like nah never
but then you're somehow getting scam but
you don't know it yet yeah you're like
getting scammed currently oh true okay
you know what I mean here I'll show you
guys a scam iPhone 4 when I was a kid
yeah and I was really sad about it this
in my day was in every video game
magazine in publication and it was
called the ultimate gaming rig and all
you had to do was solve this very easy
crossword puzzle thingy at the bottom
and then you'd send in like five dollars
to enter and then you could win all
these [ __ ] games and like consoles TV
all this cool [ __ ] like of course that
was something you're gonna want to do
yeah that's a good scam yeah in the 90s
so you solved it you're Republican oh my
God I [ __ ] did it yeah and it's super
easy and you send it in and then what
happens is after a little bit they send
you another one and they go hey you did
it you pass this level but if you want
to win even more games and prizes send
ten dollars back and do this slightly
harder crossword which was like super
easy and they would just keep
perpetuating this over and over over and
I don't know how much money I sent it
wasn't that much but as a kid this was
my actual money yeah so that's pretty
much 100 of my allowance was going to
this like thing that was never gonna end
and it went for like over a year are you
sending like cash in an envelope in an
envelope yeah oh damn I'm talking snail
mail 1992. damn
and I was extremely sad to fall for a
scam like that as a child because you
know all you do like when you look
through East Bay catalogs and look at
shoes back then or you look at a Lego
catalogs and you just imagine playing
with these toys yeah and then all day
long I'll just stare at this ad and just
go oh man I'm gonna I'm gonna get this
[ __ ] get plugged in play this game in
that game when do you wake up and
realize it's over I got [ __ ] scammed
got taken my dad would always tell me
he'd be like you waste your money you're
wasting it's a scam and he would always
tell me that and I'd be like no it's
gonna come like next month next month
and then you know apparently it doesn't
he's like you're gonna learn the hard
way you know that's kind of tight though
because from his ratio about it it's
like maybe to you is like 100 bucks
total for him he's like that's a pretty
good lesson right there it is yeah it
looks you know what I mean it's not too
bad it's a good lesson for like a
year-long lesson yeah I think these guys
like have a warehouse you know kind of
these envelopes I've been taking the
cash out and like I was teaching kid
lessons
yeah it really is and I think like now
yeah when I looked it up today and I'm
like who the [ __ ] won this prize and I
won on YouTube and there's all these
like content creators in the gaming
world that know about this and they'll
do like uh explanations about what this
whole thing was or they actually want it
nobody ever really wanted it nobody that
they can find or know of or anywhere
ever really won this thing unless it
like just went to some like throwaway
person friend of the company like the
Monopoly game pieces like the Monopoly
game pieces bro so after you guys have
heard my story has anything like this
ever happened to you in your life
I have a really shitty stupid version
that's really not a scam but it's about
me so uh one time I was looking up
buying a sword on eBay what kind of
Sword
I thought I was nerdy kind of cool was
it a final fantasy sword you [ __ ]
nerd no it's been Lord of the Rings okay
you want a needle no it was the [ __ ]
sort of aragorns which is north the
shards are not ourselves but like the
the one that got put back together
anyways I take it back it's pretty cool
Sorry Anthony but and I found one and I
found I was like do this significantly
cheaper but as a kid you know what I
mean you're just like you don't really
pay attention to the fine fine print and
then when it came in the mail it was the
size of a letter opener oh no damn it's
still like 40 bucks though oh wow like
200 or some [ __ ] yeah it's the what I
bought versus what I got yeah yeah yeah
but they take the [ __ ] photo all
close up so to scale but it was cool
though and it's in the same listing and
it's not in the title that's says letter
it's like in parentheses in the
description in a smaller part of a
corner all right that sucks it's my
lesson you have to read everything plus
40 bucks for a goddamn huge sword I mean
you you must have thought you were you
were scamming them dude
I'm gonna get 200 of these I mean come
on come on yeah I get it you still have
it to this day no this is a long this is
like when the [ __ ] Lord of the Rings
came out dude come on come on I was like
I was so young I didn't [ __ ] have
letters you know what I mean that's
funny
this is really the same thing but um I
think when I moved to LA I think I
responded to the same Craigslist ad you
and Joe responded to for these stupid
[ __ ] couches right here
because I have this I had the same couch
those aren't scams though they really do
exist yes but they're the worst couches
ever and some guy just shows up with a
[ __ ] pickup truck and just unloads it
and like like there's your couch and
like you know you just think because
they look good they look good in
pictures they look good in pictures so
they take great pictures of them too and
then when you're actually there and
you're sitting on them you're like wow
this is uncomfortable I don't sit like
on a bench in a train
like this [ __ ] is like really bad but I
definitely felt taken because it was
like 600 bucks they they made ours in
front of us do they really yeah they're
like our warehouse is all money come go
pick it up oh [ __ ] okay so we go we show
up and they're like so you're here for
one of those Craigslist couches we're
like yep and it was pretty cheap it was
like I don't know like maybe like 50
bucks or 100 bucks from one of them yeah
it was cheap and then uh well yeah we're
here for that he goes all right give me
five minutes and then you just see him
take like this wood frame get [ __ ]
the yellow cushion material and he just
pulls his [ __ ] vinyl thing out and
I'm like you're just gonna make it right
here we like freshly make them or
whatever and it's literally it's made to
order yeah to make sure they're warm
when you get on here he has couches but
it was crazy I'm like damn they're just
doing this until the Staples fast food
yeah you seem to go fast food couch yeah
that's sick I got storage I spent I was
trying to buy PS I think four off uh
offer up I was like 200 bucks and I was
like that was a good deal I met the dude
bought it from him and he showed me a
video of like oh yeah I see it works and
I was like oh cool Baron swinging this
is perfect I [ __ ] get the PlayStation
I plug it in doesn't work and I go
oh
I was like Nick
reaction and I was like you [ __ ]
idiot dude you're supposed to [ __ ]
test it out calling his number and it
goes straight to voicemail or it's like
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by audible I'm a big big fan of
audible because I love being efficient
with my time so every single time I'm
driving from Vegas back to LA or La back
to Vegas my go-to thing is pulling up my
Audible app and what's awesome about it
is you can even listen to books or
podcasts or original shows offline
because you know sometimes when you're
traveling you don't always have Wi-Fi
and right now a book that I really
really love is called Scar and Stripes
by Tim Kennedy my good friend and he
just documents like his whole upbring
from him being a kid growing up in like
the NorCal area all the way to him going
to Afghanistan to help rescue people
during the entire like Afghanistan
fiasco it's really cool because um not
only does he share all these experiences
and makes you feel very grateful to be
an American but also one of my favorite
things about audiobooks is that a lot of
times the author is the one that's
narrating it or reading it so you get
way more from the book because you get
emotion and a lot of the other things
rather than just hearing your own voice
and that's the book that I'm reading
right now and if you guys want any type
of audio entertainment go check out
audible because that's literally what
they're all about your One Stop shops
because they got audible Originals they
got podcasts they have books obviously
and like I was saying you can check out
one new title every single month so
it'll keep you entertained so let
audible help you discover new ways to
laugh Be Inspired or be entertained
because new members could try for free
for 30 days just go to audible.com off
the Record or just text off the Record
to 500-500 that's audible.com off the
Record or text off the Record to 500-500
to try Audible for free for 30 days
audible.com
off the Record and I was like trying to
find a way I was like I could find this
[ __ ] probably because I found
that he had other listings and I was
like oh I'm just gonna go try buy and
meet him yeah and meet up with him but I
was like nothing's good like nothing
good is Gonna Come From This you got got
just take the L and then move on and
that's what happened to me that's she's
sad it hurt my pride though here's a
really quick adult one that I had that
was really really messed up I bought an
iPhone like a used one and I met the guy
like somewhere around here actually and
uh it was this Asian dude he sold me the
iPhone
um I didn't verify I didn't know at the
time how to verify whether it was stolen
or not I was just like whatever I'll
activate it I ended up buying it I
didn't activate it because I decided to
just get a brand new one because the new
one had come out like before I was able
to activate this kind of old one so I
was like let me just get a new one and
then I'll just sell this one so then I
go and sell it I meet this father and
son at T-Mobile they're like oh let's
meet at the store so we can like
exchange it there I go and meet it there
they try to activate it and the [ __ ]
alarm that it's stole colon comes on the
computer and I look like the [ __ ]
thief
and you have tattoos yeah so I'm
automatically yeah yeah so then I look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] the dad was like
uh son we're just gonna go like he just
like didn't even say nothing to me and
they just bounced and then the store was
like there's a stolen phone sir and I
was like well you can have it I slept oh
I was so embarrassed dude but you didn't
know [ __ ] yeah but like there's no way
to prove that I didn't know like I just
look like a [ __ ] low life so no you
don't dude I don't think you do anything
I think you look like alola
I I think you have to put a serial
number in like and then what it'll be
registered
the
alarm
even activate if it's reported stolen
that's that number of the phone won't
even activate
I don't think I've ever been scammed
yeah Geo's still working on it because
like ever since I was a kid I was so
mischievous I think I've always been
thinking like a scammer so I think like
I've always like you know I was the kid
that's like like you know like tiger
right now right here's the [ __ ]
bounce house all the kids are in the
bounce house he's the one in the back
like unplugging it and watching it
collapse on the kids but I've always
been that
I've always been there like oh what's
behind the curtain so I've always been
thinking like that and then so like
um I always kind of just can see things
coming and I'm like oh this I think this
is a scam
so I don't think I've ever really been
like scam scam when I'm when I was I had
a roommate for a while and then he was
moving out because he got with his
girlfriend and then I was like okay I
need a roommate so I'm like going on all
those places where you place your
through your ads and [ __ ] Craigslist
everything and then I'm like getting a
bunch of people and there was this one
person who was like Hey I you know this
is me I need a place fast I'm coming in
from like [ __ ] Canada so I'm gonna
like like I'm gonna I'm gonna wire you
the money for the first month and then I
just need you to to uh Western Union
Western Union me
yeah like the change or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah they always do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so then I was like I was
like that's interesting so I go to my I
just get this check from her right it
was like a check and it was like for
five G's or something like that and I
was like
okay so what's the scan I'm just gonna
put this in my [ __ ] bank
and then once it clears then I would
Western Union money but but the scam is
you put that in your bank and then they
need the Western Union ASAP like now
like oh yeah I don't know what's good
like just just do it quickly and I was
like
um no I'm not gonna do that so I I ended
up going to my bank like like probably
45 minutes after I put it in I was like
hey I think that's a bad check
and then they put a stop to it and then
I was like you know I like Googled a
bunch of dick pics and send them to the
chick and basically like [ __ ] you you
like you didn't [ __ ] me I [ __ ] you
I think Steve is my advisor
you to help me your [ __ ] Vengeance
connoisseur you're so good at the
Vengeance I love getting revenge of
sticks I sent it over I loved it I think
the scariest time that I thought I was
gonna get scammed but it was like it
didn't seem like it was going to be a
scam was like in
2003 2004-ish
um I was trying to sell my truck out of
Tacoma at the time and
um I only had one buyer and this buyer
was gonna pay like 1500 more than what I
wanted to sell it for um so I was like
[ __ ] like that already seems kind of
fishy I'm like this is my listing price
like you don't need to pay anything else
but I also don't have any other bites
sound like [ __ ] I'm like all
right so I'll just try to continue it
because like I really want it to work
out you know and then goes oh I'm
actually going to come from Arizona so
is it cool if we meet in like [ __ ]
Barstow or some [ __ ] like that and then
I was like oh [ __ ] this is like getting
fish here and fish here this was gonna
Jack my ass and then so I was like so as
I'm like going it if I'm willing to
entertain the scam I also have to like
cover my like my tracks
so I was like all right I'll meet you
I'll meet you and I think Barstow where
the [ __ ] he wants to meet so I call one
of the other homies at the time and I'm
like hey can you like tail me in your
car and he's the kind of guy that like
uh police like to put in jail like he's
one of those type of guys and so he has
an automatic Glock that I was like if
anything happens like dumping uh do the
stuff that you usually do and then so so
we drive
Joe's like okay
we dropped the Barstow in my Tacoma we
meet at the place that we're gonna meet
and it was outside of this Credit Union
that he actually banked at and then he
comes out of his car
with his daughter and I think he's
probably using that as like an olive
branch type of thing so when I saw the
daughter and like he was just like a
really nice dude I turned back to like
like two blocks down I was like hey
what's your forehead did you radio your
sniper yeah and then we started having a
conversation Joe's like too late [ __ ]
I'm already set up [ __ ] I was
not having a conversation and then I was
asking about like why offer like the
1500 Extra like I was like you know like
I was kind of scared in this like whole
situation yeah that's what I brought my
daughter I just want everyone know
everything everything's cool because we
are meeting in the middle of nowhere and
then um and I was like yeah why'd you
offer 1500 he was like oh it's just the
truck that you had was uh fixed up the
exact way I wanted it it had like the
lift kit he just really didn't want to
let it go I don't want anyone else to
outbid I just threw it I was like oh my
God so you should have said that such a
dream [ __ ] thing to happen yeah you
should have said that because there's
people in around here that'll do crazy
[ __ ] so it's just another Bart success
story huh yeah wow just another one dude
all right come on everybody swishing it
good one sir one time I think you guys
came because I found a thousand dollars
on the ground but then it was actually a
thousand dollar check
[Music]
foreign